however because of the significantly
higher levels of infection
in the central belt we are introducing
stricter restrictions in the following
five health board areas grace of glasgow
and clyde
lannister airshirt and aaron lothian and
fourth valley
in these areas all licensed premises
with the exceptional hotels for
residents will be required to close
indoors and outdoors the takeaways will
be permitted hotels
as i said will remain open for residents
cafes which don't have an alcohol
license
will be able to stay open until 6 pm to
support social isolation
in addition snooker and pool halls
indoor bowling alleys casinos and bingo
halls will close in these areas
for two weeks from the 10th of october
contact sports for people aged 18 and
over will be suspended for the next two
weeks
with an exception for professional sport
and indoor group exercise activities
will not be allowed although the current
rules will remain in place for under 18s
gyms can remain open for individual
exercise
and outdoor live events will not be
permitted in these five
regions for the next two weeks and
finally we're asking
people living in these five health board
areas to avoid
public transport unless it is absolutely
necessary
for example for going to school or work
if homework is not an option